during uh during a black lives matter
protest i can't remember which one
i think it was in ferguson there was
somebody who wrote a letter it was a
one of the black activists saying that
they felt desegregation was it was
like a trick it was that what it did was
you had basically parallel economies
that were
you know the black community was
flourishing and then once they got rid
of segregation and integrated then all
of a sudden
it pushed all of my community into and
under
the white community yeah yeah i don't i
don't necessarily
agree with with that whole school of
thought but we can talk about it so i'd
love to hear more about what you think
about that
well they that that's the succinctly put
right there that's exactly what happened
we became second in somebody else's
stuff instead of first in our stuff
you know like one of the craziest things
that they'll say is oh this person is
the first black to
go to the moon or first black to do this
or first
that award should not go to us that
award should go to white folks
congratulations you accepted somebody
other than yourself
right and that's what that's kind of
like uh
you know a microscopic look at how we're
treated in america or how we're looked
at by the liberal america oh look
it's cool to be second place so here's
your participation
trophy this is it's kind of interesting
though because
the only time i've ever heard the idea
about segregation
being like or i'm sorry integration
being bad in some capacity
is from the left right but you consider
yourself conservative
no considering myself hotep we have
conservative values though right
okay yeah i consider myself hotep
although we have conservative values
and i i get along with a lot you know
shout out to sunny johnson you know
shout out to uncle hotel uncle hotep was
the one that taught me about
conservatism
and sunny johnson refined that that
school of thought for me
and and i think she's the best
conservative i've seen period you know
black white or whatever
um but yeah loosely described as
conservative i know a lot of people like
to describe me as that i don't mind it
sometimes but hotep to the core
yeah i think that's a good way to put it
man it's it's weird how
left and right don't really make sense
anymore i guess
no that's that's the great divide to
divide the people
yeah you know so we don't unite against
the state you know that's the big thing
and that's why white liberals keep us in
the forefront
you know the the thing about integration
was
it was about turning black people white
they wanted us to be like them they
wanted us to
amalgamate and and assimilate into the
white culture and become culturally
white
and uh whoever whoever assimilates
best does best if we look at people like
you know don lemon you know clean cut
dude he assimilates real well sounds
like a white guy dates a white guy
he assimilates really well uh kamala
harris she assimilates really well
she dates a white man she's married to a
white man
these people assimilate into aoc she
talks all that stuff about white
supremacy but she sleeps a white man
you know these people assimilate into
the culture and it seems like if you
assimilate
for example my hair would not be allowed
right
unless i was hey you know then it'd be
okay
that's so weird but these are democrats
yeah this is kind of like
a heterodox i don't know it's it's weird
it sounds like a lot of what you're
saying
does fit with with a lot of the social
justice you know activists
yeah but then you're coming down hard
and pointing out it's actually the
democrats that are
you know racist or they have no
diversity they scream diversity but they
have none
when you talk about you know the
problems in america right and they say
oh you know
unemployment well who owns all the tech
companies
it's the leftists so if there's if you
don't guys don't have
representation of women guess who's been
making those decisions
white liberal men if you don't have
black people
on your board or or on your team who
made those decisions
some white male liberal y'all in the
world
they say that they're they're they're
doing better now by
stopping the white cis heteronormative
patriarch or whatever
like it's it's these same companies that
are now trying did you hear what they
hear what you just said
say it again this is what white says
heteronormative patriarchy
okay try to be as verbose as possible
because i'm trying to i'm kind of making
fun of them you know
it and and that's very specific i know
that that's almost meaningless right
it's exactly
it's so specific that it's meaningless
yep right it's like you're
heteronormative so every
other white man's exempt from the rule
right right right
the point of saying it is to like it
highlights the absurdity of the
of this friendly group of people yes
because like a regular person is going
to be like i got no idea what you just
said
right you didn't convey any information
to me by saying that weird phrase yeah
if you're not on twitter you wouldn't
know what's going on right exactly
we gotta talk about the main mag of
march to go on from there but yeah
when they say patriarchy yeah that's
exactly what they want to do they want
to destroy the patriarchy for you
but not for them just like gavin newsom
it's
lockdowns for you but i'mma kick it with
the homies
more than once more than once i got
caught twice twice why is he got caught
you guys know who those people were
that was the california medical advisory
board
i thought that was the funniest thing
i'd heard dude like you got to be joking
it's kind of so obvious what they do
right they lock they tell you to lock
down nancy pelosi it's a haircut
mayor lori lifewicko gets a haircut
gavin newsom goes out to eat gets caught
goes out to eat again gets contest it
was just a mistake no they don't care
about you and they're not scared of this
that's what's weird yeah some animals
are more equal than others
animal farm yeah if you people haven't
read animal farm
make sure you go give that a good
refreshing read it should only take you
about
an hour or two if you got add like me
insane i had the kids read it this
summer but
so so you said you said democrats have
no diversity is that what you're saying
there's no diversity
and what so what do you mean by that you
have to think a certain way
you have to look a certain way you have
to behave a certain way
and they use skin color as the shield to
pretend they do have diversity
yeah i mean i go on these voice chat
apps and i have
discussions with them and all the black
people sound exactly the same
and then i get in the room when i speak
and i get ostracized
because i'm different because i don't
come from your world
of pish-posh polished
white liberalism you know the black
boulet
i mean the people that complain about
racism and white supremacy
have some of the best jobs yeah they
work for cnn
they work for vogue i'm like you guys
have all the jobs
i wish i would have had when i was
younger they were all blue checked up
and verified
do you know how far being verified goes
when you apply for a job
really oh yeah i know you wouldn't know
because you were smart man
well no just because i've you've never
applied for a job using a blue check
right right right yeah i've not applied
for a job in like 10 years
see what i'm saying because you're a
smart man yeah but some some people out
here
you know they want to apply for a job
and they might have dreadlocks
and they might not have that college
degree and they might not have that
verification
but you know what if i had the
verification they might overlook the
degree
yeah they might overlook the law you're
somebody right right yeah you must be
somebody mm-hmm
but take it man i don't i i went to the
white house wearing this
did you yeah i didn't wear a suit i wore
the beanie in the over and then the
shirt or whatever it's called branding
that's right it is it is but it's also
uh i think it's it's it's look man this
is america
we're a country founded on a bunch of
farmers fighting back against
you know the the the empire or whatever
yes so the way i see it is
in this country we are all equal
okay life liberties put his hat uh life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
and we are all uh uh i'm i'm brain
farting on the uh the line from the
declaration of independence
but uh we're created in god's image no
we're all created you know
with the same inalienable rights yes so
when someone says this is the white
house i say that's great but
this is not a building designed and
built for in my opinion
the wealthy and does like the wealthy
elites ooh
wait no no we can go back in time and
talk about the wealthy landowners
and their their ideas yeah what they
wanted to do
but what they put forward in these
documents was planting a seed
that said everybody's got a shot um
allegedly now you've got companies like
vanguard and state street
and uh that own like most of the tech
companies so like vanguard
is the biggest investment firm in the
world it owns and it's not in america
well yeah we got
we have i think after a certain amount
of time we became a plutocracy
yeah and now it's just all the rich
people who just dictate what we do and
they they pay for the laws dividing us
on purpose as americans
because of these i don't know
financialists i don't know
uh that's what that's what worries me i
don't know if there's like
a grand conspiracy among the ultra rich
to be like here's what we got to do to
the people
i think it's rich people just acting in
their own interests like ultra wealthy
elites
and it's a big club and you ain't in it
but i don't think they have like a
meeting where they're like how can we
screw over the rebel today
or like how can we control no i think
it's basically a guy saying i don't want
them coming in my building
so i want this law passed in your city
and they go you got it buddy
and then they they build this system
around there's but there's so many
meetings documented there's meetings but
it's it's an issue of i guess it's an
issue of intent right are they having
there was a there was a
jekyll island meeting surely you're
familiar with
the creature from jekyll island no
what's this i shall say nothing further
that's where they
that's where they wrote up the federal
reserve act the way
oh really the way i look at you know how
this country was founded
is that it's really interesting to have
these ideas of liberalism like classical
liberalism
freedom liberty individualism they
certainly didn't
uh operate under the purest form of that
when you know this country was founded
but through that we've had numerous
amendments supreme court uh
rulings that have led to more equality
i guess you can call it equality but i
suppose i i feel like i feel like the
opposite has happened
so explain the further the further we've
progressed as a country
the less equality we've had really
yeah um where is the equality
where do you see the equality well i can
tell you uh
it was my my uh grandparents weren't
legally allowed to be married because
they were different races
and so they had to actually flee because
it was illegal different states
well again that's the problem with the
federal government
right so the federal government
overrides how the states want to operate
right i believe that every state has the
right to make laws and say look
we don't want these type of people
getting married
cool i'ma leave and go someplace where
we are welcome
this is the the great thing about not
having uh
a communist nation because then you got
the federal government
opens a window for them to start calling
shots and saying you can do this and you
can't do that
we got to leave that window closed you
can't tell the states anything they want
to do
besides uh i think the only benefit to
having people get married under the
state is some sort of tax
right tax benefits it was different back
in the day it was different
i mean what's stopping you from getting
married under god
i don't know why do you need this
state's approval to get married
i agree with you on that right you want
to talk about why the government has
authority
there's a big difference between
legitimate authority and illegitimate
authority too much of government is just
arbitrary we've just okay you're in
charge of this for whatever reason it
doesn't make sense
yeah you wasn't with me sleeping in the
bed you know what i mean you wasn't
hitting that i was hitting that
yeah where was you at you know you took
30 percent from me ain't giving me
nothing back
you're talking about the government yeah
you took 30 percent
for ties and didn't get nothing back
you screwed me i i was screwing her
while you were screwing me
my understanding as i was reading this
thing we mentioned it a day ago a day
ago or so
is that the average person gets more
value
more dollar per dollar value from the
government than they pay in taxes
it's the rich people that pay way more
taxes that basically subsidizes i've
heard that theory before but
that sounds like what you call uh
overeducated speak
yeah yeah either you taking 30 from me
or not i don't care what you're doing
with everybody else and the super rich
and what they're subsidizing
are you taking thirty percent from me
because i need that thirty percent
seriously yeah so you like these trump
tax cuts yeah
even though it's a deferment right you
still gotta pay it later on
which ones the the the tax program well
the
the
the covid one was a deferment right but
but the uh
the actual tax cuts he put in place oh a
few years ago yeah yeah oh okay okay
yeah yeah of course i mean of course
you're gonna enjoy that right i operate
as a corporation
it's it's really you know the craziest
thing to me is i don't understand why
when it comes to when i talk to these
leftist activists these progressives
they're talking about taxing the rich
and all that and i'm like okay but you
know how much money of that
like do you know where that money goes
when you tax them like there's a lot of
questions you got to ask when they say
when you say tax the rich okay
what taxes are you talking about capital
gains specifically are you talking about
corporate tax
and then where does that money go what
do you do with it because i'll tell you
what like a good chunk of it goes to
blowing up kids in
you know foreign countries yeah i mean
is that something you you are choosing
to pay for you want to buy
because right i personally don't i mean
when you charge when you when you
when you tax the rich all you're
basically saying is become more savvy
with how you hide your money
yep exactly right so then you wonder why
you can't get jobs in america is because
they're gonna
offshore them to russia india or some
other
third world nation and and and that's
the result they're gonna be much savvier
you know in order to not pay taxes in
america you need a 500 an hour
dollar uh employee i mean um accountant
somebody who has previously worked for
the irs from those other loopholes
that's how you
you perform tax avoidance is different
from tax evasion got tax avoidance so if
you can afford to not pay taxes
you won't pay taxes and you shouldn't i
i do not
advocate for the rich to get taxed
because advocating for the risk to
get taxed means i'm next no
no that's not supposed to be like that
how do you feel about income tax
it shouldn't be taxed at all the first
instance of tax was for what to
subsidize the wars
when was that revolutionary war civil
war
but wasn't that that was bonds though
wasn't it like so in the revolutionary
war they sold bonds
and then i think income tax came at like
the early 1900s they were like we need
more money
they came around they had the federal
reserve they had a stamp tax
yeah yeah stamp act for a week that's
correct sir
for imported goods it was like a tariff
yeah so you might not have had an
income tax right right right right but
they were taking that out of your assets
they were stealing money from people
some way somehow
then you had the the european powers
that were controlling the script that
were controlling the currency
and that's really what everybody was
upset about that's one thing a lot of
people don't talk about
because you gotta remember they tried
the first national bank then the second
national bank and then the second
national bank was like all right we paid
off all our debts and after the civil
war the north told the south look
whatever debt you got we're not taking
that you better clear your debts before
you come back
and that's how russia uh gave us alaska
and paid off the debt
you know what i'm saying so we bought
that back from russia
for for helping the north i mean is a
lot goes into
you know the financial background of
america
but i mean there's always been some sort
of lien
placed against the american people so
you let's go back real quick you were
mentioning diversity next i want to ask
you
we were talking about the democrats yeah
they all think the same they'll act the
same
yeah but they just they say they look
different so that's their diversity
what do you think about the republican
party uh the republican party
uh they're so boring there's nothing to
say
right dude that's the way i feel like
what do they do
like like the really um i don't i don't
i don't know what the republican party
does i i have no idea
what's happening in that world i could
not speak from an educated platform on
the republican party or the democrat
party
all i can tell you is about what i see
manifested in my life
and it seems like the republicans have a
very hands-off attitude
um it seems like they they bow to
the democrats it does for sure right
yeah
from where i'm sitting and it seems like
the democrats really control the topics
of conversation they control
culture the liberals control culture and
uh like
i believe uh breitbart said andrew
breitbart you know said uh
politics is downstream from culture
correct yeah right yeah so they under
they they knew that you know republicans
don't have any culture
like they don't they don't control any
cultural institutions right the
republicans
are constantly trying to be liked by
democrats yeah like you see that video
of lindsey graham fist bumping kamala
harris the other day yeah
like he's the dude who's coming out
telling trump to fight tooth and nail
he's going to donate money to this but
then secretly he walks up he's like fist
bump pad in the back
because these these you know what you
know what it feels like a lot of these
republicans
and there's some good there's some
there's some good populists like you
know
regular conservatives and there's some
democrats yeah but the republican party
it seems like these guys are all just
like the nerdy kids in school
begging to be popular yeah and they
think the democrats are the cool kids so
they're just like we'll do whatever
we'll say whatever you want you know
just tell me what to say and i'll say it
yeah
exactly i mean they were all puppets
puppets at the end of the day
you know um alex jones came on your
platform um
actually nah my bad i'm thinking of sean
stone i interviewed sean stone on my
platform
and he broke down who was financing the
left and who financing the right and
they from the same family
i'm not naming no names i'm not that
brave does the left has anybody
have anybody funny funny yeah or funding
funny funny funny oh they got a lot of
names i don't say names that's not what
hotep jesus do we don't say names
you know what i mean yeah cause then
people drag you they're like you bring
them up and then well i might need their
money one day
[Laughter]
right all right i'm not i'm not gonna
upset see that's the thing man
everybody's like
upset at this power structure right i'm
not
upset at it i'm upset at the people
for for for feeding into it
we don't got to feed into this system we
could go do our own thing and make this
system
obsolete and and these people would be
wondering like
like you asked me like uh shorty asked
me on the way ahead you know do i vote i
was like nah i don't vote
if i vote i validate the existence of
the state i'm not validating the
existence of this state so i don't vote
so every time y'all go vote y'all
basically telling the government oh
y'all believe in this what we doing okay
good come on down here place this vote
no doubt
i got you and you're validating bs
proving you have confidence in the
system to some degree right
so like how many times do you have to
get shafted
before you realize it's not working for
you and the problem is
and that's why i'm writing my upcoming
book you know it's like
they don't have any sense of history you
know i mean people talk about the
founding fathers like i always say the
founder followers didn't care about you
at
all you know they were not thinking
about you when they wrote declaration
independence and the bill of rights they
were thinking about themselves right
i don't know i don't know if i agree but
let's let's talk about it what do you
mean
okay uh in order to uh vote
you had to own land back then but you
know why that was why is that there was
no ids
so somebody walks into a meeting and he
says i'm gonna vote and they're like who
are you
i own this piece of land here right here
yeah so it was your way of saying
i live in this community i'm a member of
this community
you know in order to have power you
always need good excuses
yeah and that sounds like a real good
excuse we didn't have id
well you know what everybody has for id
what's that
called a thumbprint but back then i
don't think they knew that what come on
tim don't think you're prince back in
the day fingerprints are ancient
fingerprints are ancient bro they used
to
take candle wax and then certify a
document with candle wax
this is ancient technology everybody's
got an idea it's right here
it's not it's not just about iding
somebody it was about
we don't want someone to vote in our you
know meetings
right who doesn't have a stake in what
happens here yeah that's what
that's what that's what they say that's
what they say
but that's not what the documents say
the documents
are supposed to be for all people right
not just
landowners right you can't just say oh
you have to have a stake in this
that's a good point too because there
are a lot of people who lived in these
areas that didn't own land
you know they weren't voting well yeah i
think you know you know
you also got people who were drafted in
the wars while the rich were able to pay
their way
out and you know uh you know the 17th
amendment
that we do a senate by popular vote okay
before
before
uh before the 17th the states would
appoint
senators specifically because this is
not a democracy this country's not a
democracy it's a republic the founding
fathers thought
you've got the house that represents the
will of the people
but the senators are the upper chamber
of better men
yeah literally that's that was what they
would say better men
and so that all changed in the early
1900s and i think it was
probably michael malus who told me this
that uh maybe it wasn't no no i think it
was sheamus
actually oh yeah that there were there
were senators who when they passed the
17th resigned
saying i do not want to be beholden to
the rebel hmm
you know so so originally yeah we did
have
elitism you know we had a lot more of it
this it was crazy to me you know you
know the uk sells the house of lords
they what they sell the house releases
they still have a house of lords oh yes
yes
the upper chamber is just like religious
you know uh ranking people
and like landowners from like of of
historic merit of some sort
yeah and then the other side is the
parliament and then i think no the house
of commons house of commons yeah so
they're all in parliament the house of
commons is just like the regular people
okay
so it was supposed to be like that here
yeah the founding fathers were like we
want better men to be appointed by
you know the state and then the house
was the regular people who would come
and you know talk about the will of the
people
yeah i think i think it's clever because
we're not a democracy
and you don't just want you know all
political power to be in the hands of
just
popular vote right makes sense but
definitely thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you